spider-man spider-man does whatever a
spider King all right so it's been rumor
for a long time people were like Gerry
you're gonna do a video about it I was
like I will do a video about it when it
becomes actually official and true guess
what guys it's official intro Sony has
allowed spider-man to come to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's like a truce
kind of thing they got going on Sony
still retains the rights to spider-man
so they're gonna make so many spider-man
movies but they worked out a deal with
Marvel were there they're like hey you
can use him for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe definitely not age of Ultron is
too late for that
probably not Captain America Civil War
and a lot of people wanted him for Civil
War but I think civil wars is too late
in production to put them in there they
might be able to squeeze him in in a
couple scenes but ultimately for the
most part Captain America Civil War is
probably gonna be Spidey Lisbon
definitely Infinity Gauntlet if I'm
wrong about that if he ends up going in
Civil War awesome that is a great
surprise for the fact that they're gonna
have so many spider-man movies then the
question becomes like well is it gonna
be the Andrew Garfield Spider Man is he
gonna be in it because Tony was like no
more Andrew Garfield he talks some [ __ ]
no more him in which case are is this
gonna be a new Spider Man a new Peter
Parker altogether might be Miles Morales
sure maybe they want to go another route
I was thinking about this [ __ ] check
this I think I got it figured out
because we don't want to see the
backstory again we have seen the
backstory we know the backstory nerdy
science kid Peter Parker gets bitten by
a radioactive spider becomes spider-man
his uncle's like I was great power comes
great responsibility of this check this
[ __ ] out what if you have spider-man you
know like spider-man without the hoses
Peter Parker and the suit he's up on a
building he's like my name is Peter
Parker I was a science geek and then I
got bitten by a radioactive spider that
would change my life forever cuz my
Uncle Ben taught me with great power
didn't know where Deadpool comes down
just boom and he's looking at the camera
he's like guys this is spider-man you
know his backstory is the third
spider-man franchise that you've been
alive for this is the second spider-man
reboot show this one some love you you
wanted it you went on the forums you
were like let spider-man in the Avengers
now you got it just like I got my
Deadpool movie thank you for that guys
you can check that out too all I'm
saying is you know it if you don't know
spider-man's backstory google it you
don't need it here enjoy have fun he
just takes off and you're like I know
everything I need to know that would be
beyond brilliant you would see Deadpool
crossover in the spider-man movie
knowing that spider-man's going to
crossover in the Avengers movie so it
ties it all together without having
Deadpool in the Avengers Sony if you
want to do that too
that would be great we'd love it and it
only took like a min
of screentime donut you can use that you
don't have to credit me at all I just
think it would be great so you'd feel
free to use that it's free I gave it to
you and know every fan who just heard it
here once it also so just do it I'm just
saying it would be a great you would
know everything you need to know about
spider-man Euler okay so the same
backstory I've always known all right
let's go I really energetic about this
this is awesome so guys I am really
pumped about this I'm glad to see
spider-man come into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's not gonna be
right away they're probably gonna have
to hash things out but if they can put
it that would be a perfect end credits
ain't maybe an age of Ultron just soon I
would love to see the post-credits scene
be spider-man
I feel like DC's like you know what guys
if you want to find me you know where to
find me at the bottom of a fifth of Jack
neck-deep and potato chips I'm done I
can't wait to see what they do with it
no need for the backstory so let's keep
going with spider-man right guys
spider-man come into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe what spider-man do
you want to see whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more